[Music]
q so graph QL you might have over by now
and if you have you've probably heard
things like health scraper performance
guy with backward compatibility great
for the developer experience and even
great for those hard to get out stains
probably a seemingly nothing group Q I
can't do but you ever wondered how how
is a graphic girl can have these
supposed superpowers and I think the key
to this is laying its basic building
blocks so in this talk we'll start off
with taking a look at the schema
definition language or STL and resolvers
to better understand how they work
together to execute a query then I'll
show some ways to use these features to
graph all the things before finally
entering the door try this at home
portion of the talk but first today
how's it going I'm Michael I'm a senior
engineer at RedBubble on the platform's
team where you work on building tolling
services and platforms to enable
everyone at RedBubble so karaoke
enthusiast and the maintainer of libsass
and notes us you can find me later in a
spectrum chemists all issues so let's
jump right into it
the schema is the skeleton of graph QL
it's what gives it its shape everything
else builds on top of what happens as a
result of the schema in graph QL schema
is defined using the schema definition
language yeah here we have an example
schema as you can see we're using the
keyword type to define a new type we've
called conference our conference type is
a name field which you said is a string
string is one of the built-in scalar
types in graph QL there are other things
like in floats and volumes of old usual
suspects next up we have a speaker's
field which has an array of speaker type
the speaker type is not one of the
built-in types so you define it
ourselves here we see our speaker has a
name and a favorite emoji this just
gives me license using emojis throughout
the talk next notice we have some field
so basically
Marx and others do not the absence of
exclamation mark just means a steward
can be omitted and is still valid also
note there are IDs there just for
convenience when curing a mutating data
speaking of querying a mutating data we
have the query a mutation types these
are special types called root types
there are others too we're not going to
talk about them today on our query type
we have a conference field that returns
any conferences we know about we also
have a speaker's field that has a
required emoji argument and returns some
speakers we have a mutation type it has
its peak field attacks a speaker ID and
a conference ID
something to note it's just common to
refer to fields on speakers and on query
mutation types simply as queries and
mutations you'll also notice a return
type Val mutation looks just like the
return type of a query field a field on
a mutation could just return things like
boolean x' but these richer types are
part of the expressiveness of graph QL
there's some detail to how these define
the we won't go into today but the
important takeaway from this is the
fields in the query type typically ask
for information whereas fills a mutation
type typically change things and lastly
at the resulting data for mutation can
be expected to have the changes already
applied yeah
if schemas are the skeleton of graph QL
resolvers are their beating heart they
bring life to graph QL with with all the
amazing things graphic UI can do you
think that'd be pretty complicated but
actually it's the simplicity of
resolvers that is a key the flexibility
it's all just a function it takes a
couple arguments we're gonna talk about
these three today but there are others
and you can define a resolver for any or
all fields on your schema this includes
fields in the query type like the
conference's field fills in a mutation
type at the speak field and fields on
any type like the emoji field on the
speaker type inside a resolver you can
do anything you could do in any other
JavaScript function the only requirement
is it returns a value in the shape that
matches the type of the field is
responsible for
here we have a map of resolvers it has a
query object representing a query type
and our query object there's a speaker's
resolver a speaker's query has an
emerging argument we can access that
argument by its name on the args
argument in our resolver we know from
our schema that the speaker's query
should return either nothing or array of
speaker types here our speaker resolver
is returning an array of objects those
objects have an integer ID field as well
as the name and all-important emoji
string fields this means they match the
expected shape of the query and all as
well remember the conference field on
the speaker type doesn't have an
exclamation mark
so it's tally optional here our speaker
mutation here we have a speaker mutation
it's loading data from the comp from the
context by the conference ID argument
context is a bit special it's a shared
global object for the lifetime of a
request this makes it useful for storing
things like configuration or services
like database connections after the
corpus is loaded the speaker ID argument
is appended to the conference object the
updated comfort subject is resisted
before finally doing a query for the
conference's that speaker is attending
right so that was a lot but it's just
the groundwork for what's coming up next
now we're going to take a look at some
practical uses for resolvers to kind of
be a bit of feel of how they work
together and really give the versatility
to graph QL the simplest resolver is
when the returns an object earlier we
saw this resolver and I said it was all
good because returned an array of
objects that match the shape of the
speaker type but how does graph cooler
now these objects match the speaker
shape is there some kind of internal
validation engine or some form of
introspection happening on the return
type or was it just a I graphical can do
all these magical things why not throw
little AI in there so no doubt there's a
bunch of ways to validate these return
types and if anything like me you've
been sitting there trying to think about
how you would done it yourself but I've
actually really shown you how it happens
every field on graph QL gets a default
resolver
the default resolver is straightforward
for any field it takes the object the
parent object and tries to either access
a field as a function call or an object
property on the parent importantly this
happens recursively so if a field
returns the type the fields return type
is a custom type then all the fields on
that type have their resolvers code this
is what happens in our case the schema
for our speakers query defines return
types either null or an array of speaker
type internally graph QL takes the
return value if it's null it's returned
otherwise if it's an array the values
iterated over and a default resolver is
called for each speaker field the parent
argument for the resolver is the object
at the current loop of the array if a
result of a field returned to the wrong
type fql throws an error also if the
return of the initial speaker's query
isn't null or an array we also get an
error
the default resolver is one of the great
examples of how schemas and resolvers
uses building blocks solve tricky
problems like validation a common use
case of graph QL is putting it in front
of existing api's this is really its
bread and butter whatever momentum start
off with but even here there's some
interesting possibilities here we've
updated our speaker query to make an
HTTP request instead of returning a
hard-coded array in the underlying API
your graphical schema could have
different types than our schemer type in
this case you would just iterate over
the JSON and could transform it's the
type you expect once again we've added
the conference resolver to the speaker
type there's a couple of really
interesting thing happening here firstly
we're using quotes jQuery and fetch
because why wouldn't you we have the
entire power of JavaScript and NPM and
all disposal in these resolvers we might
as well use it all secondly after the
speaker query has made the request to
speakers API we're iterating over the
array of speakers like I said earlier
and for each of those speakers the
converse resolver is then called from
entirely different API here graph QL is
essentially aggregating across multiple
api's in order to resolve a single query
on the remaining speaker fields are then
resolved using
default resolver remember we could have
resolved without any or all fields if
you wanted to you could resolve each
field by its own API and users of graph
QL wouldn't know anything would be
neither wiser I'm not saying you should
do this but you could if you wanted to
graph QL got a lot of attention early on
because of how well it worked as a
facade on top of these fragmented api's
api's which often had incompatible
methods of syndication different
transport types of content types using
graph QL we could expose a single
interface over years of accumulated JSON
XML rests so you have it api's without
ever having to rewrite any of them
he wasn't long before people will start
with sending these ideas sometimes
cutting out the api's altogether and
going straight to the database some
truly innovative people have gone as far
as defining the schemas themselves in
the schema different language here we're
resolving a speaker query by making a
database query given what we've this
should feel like pretty standard stuff
now we're pulling the database
connection of the shared context object
we set this up earlier because you have
the full power of JavaScript your
disposal here you can do all the things
you would do a nutritional RM and things
like switching between reader resistors
or router instances whatever the
requirements that field may be and if
you can use a database there's no reason
you can't use any other kind of data
store here are mixing and matching
between relational databases
elasticsearch clusters and Redis
clusters at the field resolver level
being able to make this operational
choices at individual field levels
enables us to pick best fit solutions
for the requirements of an individual
field and changes requirements over time
as our systems change by no means saying
this is unique to graph QL simply Amy to
illustrate the ease which is compared
these capabilities are achieved between
with interplay between schemas and
resolve was in graph QL and this is
actually my favorite use case I said
earlier that the platform's team
RedBubble we focus on labeling everyone
not just engineers and one of the ways
we do this is by letting people bring
their own tools and adapting ourselves
to work with
enter spreadsheets who doesn't love a
good spreadsheet I know I do
our PM's do our copywriters do our data
scientists do and all this rich goes on
spreadsheets are practically ubiquitous
and this makes them really a powerful
tool for enabling and encouraging
contributions spreadsheets are also
fantastic for graph QL because they're
already structured they come with their
own schemas in the form of columns and
rows here our speakers query is loading
a speaker spreadsheet from disk pausing
the CSV into JavaScript and then
filtering a speakers in a spreadsheet to
just those matching the query the emoji
we passed them to query argument now
anyone in our organization can drag and
drop a new spreadsheet on the github UI
this kicks off our CI CD pipelines
and if the tests pass this new version
the app is deployed to production and
the new data is live for what to see and
no engineer was required for this
process start I mentioned RedBubble we
have we have a lot of this graph QL
distributed and we have a lot of
configuration services to back these up
and this configuration services are bit
different rather services in at a fetch
configuration on deploy and persist
locally they're not meant to be used in
requests and additionally some services
may get over the wire updates as their
lifetime goes on we like this approach
for configuration but it comes to
complexities what is the configuration
is the configuration stored in memory or
on disk what happens when we receive an
update and then how do we validate the
new configuration we tried a few ways of
managing and exposing configurations and
our services and as you might have
expected
we eventually landed on graph QL loading
configuration files in resolver is
pretty straightforward using the FS
promises API if we're unable to load the
configuration for any reason the server
fails to boot this works really well in
many cloud environments because clearly
running and deploys will just keep
running until new versions can come up
so we don't lose any downtime
next up internally we create a
configuration object by querying for
that graphical configuration
if some important data is missing or if
the debtors otherwise unsuitable the
query fails and the service fails to
boot again here graphically I was acting
as an internal API abstracting irva the
node filesystem API and also if fretting
over the complexities of dealing with
configuration validity and freshness so
some of you may have noticed that
previous slide is the chicken and egg
scenario right how do we load
configuration and put it into context if
we're loading the configuration insider
is over and this is where we're just in
kind of nifty we create multiple
graphical servers in one server with
their own schemas and resolvers I had
one server handles incoming requests and
reloads configuration by querying that
second graph to our server that's right
you can even use graphic URL to abstract
our graph QL running on the same machine
in fact just about any API that is
simply reads and writes can be
represented as graphical queries and
mutations so this is a real lightbulb
moment for me and got me thinking what
if node APRs were just graph QL
what if our JavaScript API is for graph
QL what if all the browser is had a
graphical interface
what if script put everything and this
is my friends where things go off the
rails
welcome to the don't try this portion at
home don't try this at home portion of
the talk so I hope by now been able to
convince you that just about any read or
write interface can be like plastered
over with graphical representation so
this has got me thinking the browser has
read and write api's surely these could
have some graphical interfaces as it
turns out there's nothing about graph QL
that inherently limited to server
environments as long as you have a
schema resolver map immerse the
JavaScript of graphic well
implementations will happily run in the
browser but why and I think there's a
couple good reasons for this we live in
a world of like heavy browser feature
fragmentation and even one knows
features exist like they rolled out a
progressive manner with API
fragmentation across those features
there's also the complexities of dealing
with progressive enhancement or graceful
degradation and largely just cuz it's
fun
admittedly I did it for the fund but I
think there's something valuable in the
idea of a standard interface across all
our web languages so let's take a look
at some examples we've looked at how we
use resolve ways to interact with data
stores like relational databases and
Redis but the browser has a bunch of its
own data stores we have the web storage
API is in local storage and session
storage we have web SQL databases index
DB and if db2 and cookies and with a bit
of creativity you can stuff any kind of
data inside of a URL there's a really
handful of libraries that do this for us
act as a standard interface across a
bunch of these storage engines using a
mix of feature detection of polyfills
and substracting of a data source is
something graph QL is already good at so
it's a really great fit for this
scenario here we've taken the
spreadsheet example from earlier but
instead of reading a file of disk we're
using any of the store NPM package as an
abstraction of a various browser storage
api's libraries like store will either
progressively enhance or gracefully
degrade depending on which api's are
available in the current environment
more importantly the user of api's don't
need to juggle all the different api's
themselves nor do they learn a whole new
third party API they're just looking at
the schema for the types required and
executing queries mutations as they're
ready know how to on the server just
like on the server the browser has
perhaps equally capable of making that
request to api's and just like on the
server we can call it with the api's
within the resolvers just like with
Dennis torps we can gracefully degrade
it depending on what's available in the
current operating environment and that
my friends is running graph QL in the
browser I think that's pretty cool so I
thought I just ended here like in many
ways browser j/s is not much different
from the server-side j/s so it isn't
surprising we're able to use graph QL as
an obstruction layer over some finicky
api's but there are some things unique
to the browser does graph QL will hold
up in this new world
for example our good old buddy the Dom
now Domo struction libraries are
anything you at least some of us here
started our JavaScript journeys with
things like dojo and mootools prototype
or jQuery
even your life is like reactive in view
you can lodge if you looked at as dull
obstruction libraries here's a quick
example of what a schema might look like
to support document doc query selector
and duck with the query selector all all
the dollar sign function in jQuery and
this is what the resolvers might look
like we have a document query to get to
our document object and our document
type has it'll maybe eyes we care about
is fields
the result was for those fields just
call methods on the parent the parent
being document in this case and things
are pretty much work as expected like by
now you should be surprised by anything
on this slide it's just like all the
previous examples have seen before the
question you might have is why like why
even do this and I get it I was up front
these aren't necessarily good ideas
they're just ideas but honestly slides
like this I think is why every time I
forget to await my fetch I really to
have JavaScript yell at me that I can't
use top level of whites is why every
time I forget nerd lists aren't actually
arise is why every time I decide whether
it have to decide whether it is a
callback or a promise interface is why
all the reasons you might still use
jQuery today because it's easier is why
something about these slides really
speaks to me but I have to concede
building and maintaining a schema like
this for the entirety of the Dom is kind
of absurd like I get shivers just
thinking about what it would take to
maintain so maybe some enterprising
folks could generate schemas and
resolvers by scraping things like mdn or
w3c specs or get creative with like a
bit of web IDL or maybe what if we just
don't have the schema I know I just
spent 20 minutes telling you schemas are
amazing
after the skeleton of graph QL that's
all true but also I'm really lazy like
super lazy did you see that schema it's
massive and it's not getting any smaller
over time and so I guess if we don't
have schemas we probably don't need
resolvers either
I know I know like they're beating heart
of graph QL blah blah blah lifeblood
blah blah blah but on the other hand
still very very lazy so if you don't
have schemas and don't have resolve was
what he left with now we're back to our
friend the
for resolver now I don't know about you
but if I squint my eyes and took my head
he's a bit of imagination this kind of
looks like the resolver we had in our
thumb api's so what if we just define
our own default resolver a single
resolver that was general enough to
handle any field for any Dom API if it
follows a general pattern of fields
being properties or functions on their
parents then we don't really need the
schema like the Dom is the schema like
MD n becomes our schema I thought was a
nifty idea is I kind of give it a shot
I think we've stated enough code on
slides so let's check it out in action
so I have some demos coming up and I
think this stuff is pretty cool but I've
been told it's probably just me so if
you think this stuff is kind of cool how
about giving it a clap so I know to
continue
so in each of the time have demos
repaired earlier so as I mentioned we
could abstract over things like Network
requests so here we're making a request
to some random API that someone kindly
allowed cause on for me and so you can
see here we're just essentially querying
for our window object and on that object
calling fetch an inferred for just
passing an array of arguments that line
up to the argument order of the fetch
API so here we're just saying fetch this
URL and then we call the JSON method on
that response so under the covers you
may await this you may then this but you
don't have to care about it
which is taken what is done for you and
here we can see the output just for the
you know saying I'm not lying and you
can get the result here by calling the
path on which you made the wreck which
we made the query so our result window
fetch JSON so like you may think this is
just like we've already shown how
resolvers can make that work requests
but this is different and it's not a
resolver making a network request the
query itself is the request we're
resolving how to make requests that's a
bit has to be unique I think so that's
all well and good but what about the Dom
I promised the Dom so here we're
emulating what I talked about earlier
we're taking the doc McCrea document on
that document within querying the query
selector role and giving it an argument
saying what all the P tags on the
resulting P tags
we're pulling properties off I think it
was like a map like we what we've saved
here is you don't have to know what this
returns is it an array is not an array
how do we cast an array can i for of on
this thing is it going to yell at me all
those errors you've probably run into
like I have and we can see the output
here because the property is coming out
[Applause]
that's not gonna impress you let's try
this one out so here we're doing the
same thing except we're using graph QL
aliases so we're essentially saying a
little different here were passing a
document in we're saying this is the
route purely for the sake of indentation
and readability but also to sure that we
can actually operate on the result of
something else so passing in document
we're now doing three queries of the Dom
and actually signing those results to
essentially variables so here we're
saying our good boys are requiring for
all the Doge emojis and so as you might
notice there are some dogs and there are
some hot dogs yeah we're also querying
for the non doges and finally for the
yummy Doge I mixed our output here these
show the results of the variables but
really hit really bring this home I can
actually pass this variable back into
another query as the context and here
was essentially doing a mutation we're
calling set attribute on that on our
first goodest boy and we're giving it a
style and increasing the font size and
if we scroll up oh I changed the name
if we scroll up huh
[Applause]
if we scroll up hey John hot dog as you
may have guessed this is the hungry boy
all right so we can query the Dom we can
mutate the Dom what else can we do we
can also do animations on the Dom using
net web animation API so here we're
getting our hungry boy once again and
then we're using a web animation API by
calling animate on the resulting thing
and giving it the object of the the
webination my expects so here we're
spinning it and scaling it up and down
and we can change any of these like this
is all live I'm not lying to you
this is like so here we've had to all we
have to do is look at MD and find the
API and it's the same query interface we
didn't care what it returned to how it
worked but what if want to reuse the a
whatever when we use the animation have
we copied animation around and reuse it
and here you can using the graph to our
fragments here we're querying two
different Dom nodes in our gummy boy and
our non dogs and we're given clear
animation so give me a spin animation
and a bounce animation and these are
just defined down here as fragments on
the element type we have one the bounces
and one the spins and they're named as
such so if we uncomment this whoa
[Applause]
ah animations as variables that's the
best I got him sir but I know some of
you are thinking Dom who uses the Dom
I'm all about that jQuery life and for
you we have this we're passing our
jQuery as the root context and having
just colgate jQuery as normal we're
doing our request for the item I
recalling animate function and our
animating CSS properties and the way you
would in jQuery and these can all be
used together there is no limit to the
hilarity that can ensue with enough
animations so let's give this one more
spin before I wrap up and there we go
graph QL on the Dom in the browser
so in closing I started by saying
graphic your superpower is how to a
couple of really simple ideas and
schemas and resolvers and shaped
everything else look like a schema and a
resolver this resolves all the way down
design I think is pretty fantastic from
a graph QL infinitely versatile so maybe
with little creativity we can graph QL
all the things I move towards a
universal query language for the web I
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]